краєзнавці мирного харкова то голоси
агресивного на тоф папича см
аналогічних жартів
зате допоможуть такого розмаїття to just
dance ми всі переосмислити
історичний шлях та
а осі за допомогу і просто їх чи не
зображені не просто жити а просто їх
людей на окупованому донбасі мати
художниці алевтини кафе за рахунок ізотів
на ват і дант
купила за 2 кілометри нас в інтер чуючи
тамбів мобільний зв'язок
історія та про цвинтарі вся історія та
прокладає коен цьому сиджу
зустрічалися а це стало так і місцям для
комунікацій та ринок які прикро гуси
їх та он і ділилася її шию і водою і
інформацію інформації не матч вона стала
платформою для вас сенс аня ідіть ви
буваєте на сході України для дискусії
художники без надриву поважаючи куратором
виставки які на дьоготь
важко знайти територіях до такого що
знає і місця це козу стригти могла
буде ніби себе івашку знає і люди
річки малі з милими змова це у нас
приїхав і душ з милими художник з
росії ківі відкрито ви знаєте я вниз
російської агресії і на б я ті говорю
це процес
то українську б ви знають що я проблеми
і самі українці
потрібна національне примирення з
проблемою в Україні самій теж які
зажадають національного примирення вся
виставка з проба художники проти стоять
і veneno на тому вчиш йому будьте а в
загалом у образу вів'єн та роботи
показувати реально жити і роту на базі
таза голом в Україні німецької аудиторія
змогла подивитись на конфлікт і наші to
safely
зате допомагаю з виглядом цю ситуацію у нас
піднімеш за видами ля youtube росії в
кожного своя правда купається на заході
scorpions корпусі
замотуємо і твинки вас комори чалів
ти ніяких задумів так гостро були
вестового дні сирків кельна все зварить
на вигляд ви мід і людей майстерності на
пропаганду і часто зустрічається у
мас медіа